i really want to get on leslie and  lipsy's good side but it's a little  awkward because i've never  had to meet with her sisters for  anything they've never wanted to talk to  me about anything  so i'm nervous  i'm excited for food  yes me too all right whoo rico  wow is that crazy  there's totally a crab in there that's  so cool  but that's not for you  whoa  oh there you go  oh there's your soup all right i think  she forgot the crab  no it's because leslie got you a  different dish oh there's a different  one yep okay  is  there's a little fatty  why are you guys just staring at me eat  let's eat together  you are eating  a penis  what  that  is  eat it  this is yeah yes  balls  is this a joker  are you messing with me like dude i  don't understand  it is disgusting the only way i can  really put it into perspective is if you  had a ball of like really fatty  buttery  mushy  lard  do you have like a problem with me or  like  i had a lot of problems with you  [Music]  you